this is one of the most popular shonen
heroes of all time and yet for some
reason no one seems to understand why so
in this video i'm gonna explain exactly
what makes izuku such a fantastic
protagonist
[Music]
midoriya or as his kind and not at all
abusive childhood friend bakugou called
him deku a nickname for someone who
can't do anything
is a surprisingly controversial main
character for many people while he takes
off an impressive number of shonen
tropes like his unique power
his tragic childhood or his constant
strive to up his abilities deku also
gives off a way more vulnerable insecure
and feminine vibe than many of the
typical shonen heroes even though all or
at least most of them share similar
insecurities
however despite wielding the strongest
quirk in the story is surprisingly open
about these insecurities as well as his
emotions and his generally empathetic
nature and it's exactly this twist on
the stereotypical hard-boiled tough guy
protagonist who buries all negative
thoughts and emotions deep within
himself that seems to give midoriya a
bad reputation with some anime manga
fans and yet it's exactly this openness
about his own feelings and weaknesses
that make deku and his journey to
becoming the greatest hero of all time a
story that is more than worth following
along it's a story about growth both on
a personal level and on the level of
society making boku no hero way more
complex and deep than it appears to be
on the surface and so to understand what
makes deku such a fantastic main
character we will look at his
personality and story arc his major flaw
as a character as well as his
relationships with vakugo and tomura and
how both shape the story around him this
is the story of midoriya izuku
[Music]
now the first thing you need to do if
you want to understand any character in
any story is figure out what the central
theme the central moral argument of sad
story is that the author tries to convey
through the characters and the plot you
know what's the take home message when
we're all done here in the case of boku
no hero after over 300 chapters now it's
quite clear that the central moral
question that horikoshi is exploring is
both surprisingly basic and complex at
the same time
what does it mean to be a great hero
but this question implies a lot more
than you might think because the story
explores this problem by contrasting two
polar viewpoints individualism and
collectivism in other words what does it
mean to be a great hero on the personal
level and what does it mean to be a
great hero from the viewpoint of society
right from the start we're told that
midoriya wants to become the greatest
hero that saves everybody you know a
statement so vague and so shonen that
i'm 95 sure that he recall she chose it
on purpose so he could put his own twist
on it and so at the same time we also
get introduced to the society that
similarly seems to be as straightforward
and simple as it gets you know the
peaceful citizens are protected by the
good heroes from the bad villains
painting this quirk society as a
peaceful utopia only that everyone has
superpowers
[Music]
and despite everyone having a unique
work here this society is normal when
everyone's special
no one's special and when you take the
moment to really think about it for a
second the wording that hirokoshi uses
here is also very clever the story about
heroes and villains sets our
expectations for these groups as starkly
as humanly possible at the beginning
especially as in the first couple of
arcs both groups fulfill these
expectations pretty much perfectly
villains do bad things and the heroes
stop them to save and protect everyone
you will never find
a more wretched hive of scum and villain
and yet it doesn't take all too long
until you realize that this initial
black and white view of the boku no hero
world is not reality but we are
literally sharing midoriya's faulty
world view for a large part of the story
midoriya thinks that being a great hero
means saving people being assaulted by
bad villains that cause all the pain and
suffering in this otherwise perfect
society
[Music]
and so his major flaw as a character is
his fanatic idealization of this hero
world that is projected on the number
one hero almight that midoriya almost
worships like a god
so now you might ask why exactly does
deku think that way well in general i
think that this society in itself seems
to propagate this simplified image of
good and evil as well the deeper answer
can be found with the deuterogenist of
the story
deku has endured verbal and physical
abuse from bakugou for over 10 years
he's 15 now so that means for over
two-thirds of his life in this society
that is shaped and defined by quirks and
that lives under the guard of the hero
profession
deku is one of the rare cases where
quirk has not manifested in other words
he's just a normal human being like you
and me which makes him relatable only
that in this society of superpowers this
makes him the true outcast
now being a very kind-hearted and
altruistic person by nature that wants
to help people
having no quirk put so much distance
between him and his dream of becoming a
hero that deku had no other choice but
to either completely idolize or detest
them the fact that bakugou kept treating
him like a piece of trash for not owning
a quirk manifested such a strong sense
of low self-worth and insecurity within
him that when he finally got the chance
to actually become a hero against all
odds he embraced this one thing he
always wanted as all good and
all-powerful
completely incapable of seeing its flaws
i mean you know even after bakugou kind
of stopped constantly picking on deiku
you still see him twitching and
stuttering whenever he's around him
again and again taking away from the
confidence that midoriya slowly builds
over time by mastering one for all and
fighting for and with his friends i
honestly believe that this is quite
often overlooked but as he says himself
in this panel here midoriya truly hates
bakugou for this he admires him ever
since they were young yes but he hates
him for the way he treated him and it is
the low sense of self-worth that bakugou
beat into him over and over and over and
over that makes deku blind to the
reality around him idolizing the hero
profession so much that he kept putting
his health and his life on the line to
such an absolutely ridiculous and
unhealthy extent that it quickly became
worrying to everyone around him
and so while the impulsive and
egocentric bakugou has to learn to be
more considerate of others something
that i will discuss in detail in his
analysis the neurotic and altruistic
midoriya has to learn to respect himself
more and make harder decisions in order
to actually be able to save others i
think the perfect example of this
insight beginning to dawn on him is when
izuku can't save bakugou as he has
already sacrificed both his arms
[Music]
because for the longest time proving
himself to be worthy of inheriting one
for all and becoming a hero is way more
important to him than his own well-being
even if it also means being less
effective and useful to others not a
very smart move now while midoriya's
need for self-realization and maturity
is quite evident early on in the story
it takes quite a while to reveal the
other aspect of midoriya's flaw the
ambiguous and dark side of the hero
society
however more and more you learned that
this world where good heroes save the
innocent citizens from the evil villains
is a lot more morally gray and complex
than you originally thought and so as so
often is the case with apparent utopias
and stories it turns out that it's the
hero society itself that produces its
villains in the first place as big
surprise most people aren't actually
born evil but become who they are as the
result of their circumstances yes
there's also some explorations of the
concept nature versus nurture in boku no
hero but primarily hirokoshi focuses on
external circumstances
why does everything have to be
complicated exploring what makes people
into villains is a major aspect of the
story that is explored in a number of
ways going as far as making the villains
the main character of certain story arcs
and the central symbol for this is of
course none other than shigaraki tomura
the anti-deku whom we follow on his path
to becoming the strongest villain
firstly we understand that in this
society of quirks there are two
fundamental flaws both of them are
explored over and over again the first
of these is the notion that people with
destructive or dangerous quirks are
treated as outcasts and incompatible
with society now this is of course a
pretty straightforward metaphor for
general racism in the real world
discrimination based on physical
attributes one has absolutely no control
over
no matter if it's
twice at some point we get that these
people don't have terrible quirks
because they're villains no they are
villains because they have terrible
quirks an absolutely fantastic example
for this is arie who mirrors tomorrow's
story almost completely with the only
exception that the heroes actually end
up coming saving her as they failed to
do with tomura now the second flaw of
the hero society is the profession of
heroes itself that we already know is
far beyond all good and noble but
additionally has eradicated the common
sense of compassion and altruism in the
society at large creating a sort of
common bystander syndrome
this point is especially pronounced in
tomorrow's backstory instead of helping
this lost child people simply assume
that some hero will do the job not
bothering to do anything themselves and
so the message here is that ultimately
it's the society of heroes themselves
that creates most of these villains by
failing to do what midoriya idealizes so
much about them
saving everyone
now this is interesting because as you
know midoriya and tomorrow of course
mirror each other extremely closely with
deku himself being a victim of
discrimination and neglect only that he
gets taken in by the hero all might
while tomorrow gets taken in by one for
all don't forget that tomorrow also
wanted to be a hero and yet midoriya is
only starting to recognize very very
slowly this truth about the world that
the society of heroes that he has
thought to be so perfect is not so
perfect after all and that brings me to
daegu's character arc and what actually
makes him a true hero even if it takes
quite a while in the story to get there
the payoff however is just the better
feels good
feels good
really good real real real good as a
result of these two character flaws no
self-worth and blinding idealization of
the hero worlds what emerges only very
slowly but very clearly throughout the
story is that midoriya's arc is about
understanding the complexity and faults
of society while at the same time
growing past his personal flaws to truly
become a hero that can save everyone
even no especially someone as apparently
unredeemable as tomura who by mere
chance was forced to take the path
opposite to izuku and this arc is in
full progress now especially in his more
recent encounters with tomorrow midoriya
is starting to see the world for what it
is yes heroes help and are very
important to keeping the balance in a
world full of dangerous superpowers but
the system is neither perfect nor
unfailable
[Music]
similarly he's starting to grow as well
as a person as with the mastering of his
abilities and all the setbacks he had
from going overboard with his
self-sacrificial attitude he has started
to mature fight smarter think more about
himself and overall starts to form his
own opinions and beliefs about what it
means to be a great hero and i think
this slow emancipation from all might
and the other heroes he always admired
is really important because imitation is
a strong theme within the story over and
over we've shown that trying to be
exactly like someone always leads to
tragedy and failure
[Music]
instead horikoshi promotes the idea that
taking inspiration from those you admire
is great as long as you walk your own
path and find your own way of doing
things we see this with ida who tries to
be like his brother with todoroki and
his mother twice and all of his clones
and of course deku and bakugo who both
try to imitate their respective ideal of
all might no matter which of these
countless examples you take they always
end in failure imitating someone else
brings suffering not self-realization
[Music]
and so ironically enough it is deku's
incredibly pure and straightforward
character that changes the minds of many
of these people ida todoroki etc and
finally deku also starts to realize this
more and more himself almight wasn't
perfect as he also couldn't save
everyone instead deku starts going his
own path unlocking new powers of one for
all while realizing that saving everyone
also includes those that the current
society has abandoned i think the
kickoff to this development is this
moment right here where midoriya
realizes that instead of punching like
all might it might probably suit him way
better to actually kick
genuine goodness and desire to help
others his immeasurable courage and
ability to change the hearts of those
around him that make him a true hero and
while it understandably might be
frustrating at first to follow him as a
protagonist who starts from a very
very negative point on his character arc
the more the story and deku progress the
bigger the payoff for actually sticking
with him become